um the finish line so I will be try to
be brief okay so this is joint work with
my PhD student making Monday at the
ephah so this talk is about
understanding or some sort of
frustration about understanding depth to
threshold gates so let me just start
with the simple definition remind you we
have seen a lot of things about linear
threshold gates in this workshop
especially last afternoon so this is a
linear threshold gate where we have the
inputs and this inputs feed into this
gate with a width with various weights
and these weights are typically
unrestricted so you can think of them as
real numbers or equivalently you can
think of them as integers and then they
could be exponentially large and then
there is an in general there's an
activation function which in our case
would be the step function so that's the
linear threshold gate and this I don't
have to tell to this audience the
importance of this especially in these
days of machine learning so we
understand a lot about this from early
on in this workshop we would like to
understand what it can't compute and if
you think about it it's not hard to see
that the cardinal example of what such a
gate cannot compute would be the parity
function because you know the parity is
very nonlinear sort of Wiggles down if
you symmetrize parity look at its
spectrum it's always changing its side
and something like a linear function of
course can't do it so formally speaking
the sine degree of the parity function
is Omega n which means that any
polynomial which wants to sign represent
the parity function requires full degree
any multi linear polynomial over the
boolean Q and this the linear threshold
function of course our sine degree one
so this is a famous theorem due to
Minsky and Papert from long back and
this shows that parity is not an lt1 so
by so I represent my notation here will
be well will have you know depths of
linear threshold circuits lt1 just means
depth one and polynomial size
so we understand this so that's that's
satisfying now let's put go to depth to
network so just a very natural problem
now instead of having just one layer of
linear threshold gates we have two
layers of linear threshold gates
question is again what can it not
compute
seems like a very basic question it
doesn't take too much time to realize
that now you can compute functions with
high sign degree like parity in fact in
linear size and in fact you can compute
all symmetric functions you can compute
iterated addition and other interesting
functions and as I said I will represent
these kind of circuits with lt2 which
means polynomial of threshold of
threshold so the question is what can
these functions compute can the compute
multiplication of two integers division
well we don't know we even don't know
whether if satisfiability can be
computed efficiently by these networks
and this seems like a really really
basic problem I mean just step two
linear threshold networks we have no
explicit lower bounds not even next so
well I mean don't feel too bad about it
the purpose of my talk is to possibly
give some reasons why this is why this
might be non-trivial to do so let's see
what happens if we restrict wait since
we can't compute unrestricted depth to
we can't understand the power of
unrestricted depth to linear networks
let's try to see what happens if we
restrict the weights of each gate
and yeah it's always the step function
interpreter in this story same always
the step function got the signals can be
different the Thetas can be different
the step can the step can shift so what
happens if we restrict weights well let
me first convince you that restricting
weights do make does make life easy for
example here are basic half-spaces or
linear threshold functions
this is equality which just checks
whether 2 n-bit strings x and y are
equal and you can write it in as a sort
of a linear equation of course with
large weights ok this other function is
the very familiar function greater than
where we want to end check if X is
greater than equal to Y x and y are
again n between teachers and you can
write it in this way so this is an exact
threshold function because we want to
check for exact equality and this is the
usual threshold function and what we
know from basic communication complexity
is that the communication complexity of
both these functions greater than an
equality is omega n there's a variety of
ways of proving it you can you can
consider the rank of these matrices the
boolean matrices they are full rank and
therefore the communication complexity
is full whereas if you look at a
majority gate now a majority gate you
can think of for this talk it wouldn't
matter you can think of as the weights
being 0 1 or you can think of the
weights being just some polynomially
bounded number integer so the weight the
communication complexity of a majority
function is order log n and so that's a
one way of arguing that you know these
functions cannot be represented by low
weights so weights can help and
therefore so I will introduce this other
notation bear with me this is the last
one so this hat would mean you know the
corresponding circuit where every linear
threshold gate is restricted to a
polynomial weights you may think of them
as just majorities so in depth 1 we have
a separation by a simple argument so
let's now look at more depth and in fact
it will turn out that there is actually
sort of a rich hierarchy bit from depth
1 to depth 2 for that let me introduce
this function inner product which is I
don't have to tell this crowd what it is
it's just the standard scalar product of
two and bit strings and then I mod it
out by two an important result of again
from long back due to chor and go drag
is that this functions communication
complexity is extremely hard in the
sense that even if you want to sort of
do slightly better than random guessing
you know as as large as like one over to
the little o of n you have to
communicate a lot Omega n bits so this
is a classical result has been very
influential and what is its consequence
for us the consequence is the following
now if I look at depth two networks
where I have restricted all the gates to
have small weights they are majorities
okay it's we will see that such circuits
cannot compute the hard function in a
product and it's actually a very simple
argument but very nice which is that I
will I will say that the communication
complexity of whatever function here
computed is small why so because you
know Alice and Bob what they can do is
Alice can sample a random sub circuit
feeding into this top cake and then send
it over to a Bob here I'm assuming that
we have private coin randomness which
will be convenient for this talk and
this will require log s bits to be
transmitted to Bob because the fanning
of this top gate is s and then you know
Alice will just tell Bob the number of
ones that she sees on his on her side
and then both can compute the value of
this sampled gate and it's not hard to
see that you know this with good
probability the protocol will be right
in the sense that you know you will do
one over to s better than random
guessing right so if s is small like
polynomial or even just slightly
sub-exponential you get some exponential
advantage over random guessing whereas
the amount of communication is still
much smaller than n so this means
therefore that IP cannot be computed by
small size
majority of majority circuits because of
the tool were like strong bound that I
talked about okay so now what are the
known limitations of depth to this tells
us that this sorry this result that I
alluded to was due to Heine little from
87 which showed that IP needs to do the
Omega and size and this is a discrepancy
argument so the question is now what
what happens if I look at majority of
threshold circuits in fact if you go
back to the previous argument you could
do the same thing there without any loss
but what is surprising is that in this
sort of important work due to Goldman
hosta there are swore off from 92 they
showed that these two classes turn out
to be exactly the same
this is just within a polynomial factor
apart and this is sort of quite
interesting so it seems like if you add
weights at the bottom it does not matter
and in the same paper they also show
that if you add weights at the top it
does matter meaning there is a function
in threshold of majority here this
threshold is unrestricted everything
else is restricted to have small weights
then this class is strictly more
expressive it can compute functions that
are hard for majority of majority so now
we have the following weight hierarchy
so as I said the greater than function
separated these two this was separated
by parity then surprisingly Goldmann
hostile Roseboro shows that these two
classes are the same they also show that
this is strictly contained over here
with this this class is strictly
contained in threshold of majority and
at that time this was not clear except
the containments even the containment
needs an argument to be shown to to
argue that why this is contained in you
know weight restricted def tree and that
was again shown by Goldman hostel just
borrowed so the question is is threshold
of majority in in LT read this as LT 3
hat is it in LT 3 hat and the other
questions
that's the first question the other
question is you know do weights at the
bottom ever matter when you're dealing
with depth to circuits
so here's how one would argue about
threshold of majority let's go back to
the same setting let's look at this
slightly different communication the
communication protocol is going to be
almost the same Alice and Bob now want
to computer again this function now
instead of uniformly randomly sampling a
sub circuit what Alice does if she looks
at the probability distribution induced
by the weights of the top gate that's a
natural thing to do and then she samples
a sub circuit proportional to this
probability distribution and sends it
over again to Bob okay so the
communication is precisely the same the
total cost however now the advantage
that she gets that Alice and Bob get
could be substantially slower like these
weights could be very large and so all
you know is like you know it's just one
over the sum of the weights advantage it
could really be small but it's nonzero
so you do get the right answer with just
barely beating the random guess
probability of 1/2 and now we will
consider this is this brings true to my
the main topic of my talk now is we will
consider such protocols which seem
extremely relaxed in the sense that you
need to do barely better than random
guessing ok just greater than 1/2
strictly greater than 1/2 otherwise all
bets are off and this protocol was also
this class of protocols are called upp
protocols they're the analog of the PP
class in Turing machine complexity and
this was introduced by patooie and Simon
back in 84 and so what we show is that
what this implies is that if a function
has small sized threshold of majority
gates then at least this class of
protocols can compute such functions
efficiently so how do we prove lower
bounds against such protocols they seem
to be very very powerful so the first
question to ask is is IP nu P P and this
brings us to the notion of sign rank so
this is a very nice notion turns out to
be completely equivalent to having
efficient UPP protocols so what's the
definition of sign rank so
if I take any nonzero matrix M here's
the minimum rank needed by every real
matrix to represent it in a sign
honouring way meaning every entry of my
new matrix a in sign must be exactly the
same as the sine of M IJ and so the
smallest Ratan
rank such matrix a would be called the
sine run so it's kind of a rigidity kind
of notion except that in normally when
you consider matrix rigidity you don't
have to you know you only allow
perturbations and a few places and those
perturbations need not be sine honoré
here you are allowed to perturb at every
point but you have to maintain the site
and what petrea and Simon carefully and
very beautifully observed as that the
unbounded protocol complexity unbounded
error complexity of any function f is
precisely equal to the log of sine R and
of of this front of the communication
matrix over there let me to motivate
assign rank and to get a better
perspective let me look at it slightly
differently from a geometric point of
view so sign rank has also been
considered in other contexts in learning
theory and other places where it's
called the dimension complexity and why
so so let's look at this matrix so this
is just a four by four matrix which
makes the greater than upper triangular
matrix so I've just filled it with what
all once at the top and minus ones at
the bottom now it's rank is four and in
general if I have it n 2 to the N by 2
to the N such matrix of course it's rank
would be 2 to the N but let's look at
what let's look at it sign rank and
geometrically I can I want to I want to
place a set of points and hyperplanes in
some euclidean space such that this by
looking at the the way the hyper planes
partition the set of points I should be
able to get back my target matrix so in
this case you know I just place these
points on a line in our in two
dimensional Euclidean space and of
course these are the hydroplates that
are shooting through the origin and it's
not hard to see that if I look if I take
a deep
back of these points and hyper players
this exactly represents inside this
matrix right and this is just in two
dimension so there so no matter what the
what the dimension of this matrix was
such a matrix has sine rank somewhat
surprisingly only two okay so the
greater-than function therefore in
general would have sine rank two which
was a hard function at least for
deterministic communication complexity
and even for randomized requires log of
n now requires just two bits of roughly
two bits of communication in this
powerful and bounded error model so let
me look at one last example very quickly
now the Equality function in likewise
you can place points I have placed it in
two dimensional space but you know in
two dimensional space again we place it
on a circle and you can separate them
but I need this hyper planes to sort of
go through the origin so that's why I'm
thinking it offers it's like the
cross-section it's in three dimensional
Euclidean space and therefore the sign
rank of equality will be three and you
could show that you can do no better so
sign rank of equality drops down to
three this equality has again very small
sign rank by itself so for a long time
it was not I mean it's not immediately
clear why why in fact any function
should have large sign rank and this
result due to a long Frankel and rhodol
about a year after the patootie Simon
paper showed quite non-trivial e that
there are at least four random functions
F the sign rank will be maximum and this
requires a some deep theorem from
algebraic geometry so after a long time
Forrester made a real breakthrough when
he was able to show an explicit function
namely the inner product function to
have again very close to maximal sign
rank more interestingly what Foster was
able to show this is a very nice petrel
condition that would allow you to lower
bound sine R and what he showed was that
if M is such a sine matrix n by n then
it's
is at least in by the operator norm of
him
and if you look at function like in a
product which is like a Hadamard matrix
it has you know you can you immediately
get the the design rank is going to be
two to the n sorry 2 to the N by 2 and
this would give you the show you that
you people you people cost of computing
inner product is it's very large and
this is really surprising so because
even if you allow it to just just to
barely better than half you have no
choice but to basically communicate n
bits and this shows that by the
connection that I showed before that IP
needs to do the Omega and size threshold
of majority circuits ok so let's look at
our updated weight hierarchy so here we
are
threshold of majority is now strictly
contained in LT 3 because inner product
if you think about it is it's a simple
observation that you can do it in depth
tree so now we are left with this sort
of question well we can't prove a lower
bound for LT to yeah this this is a
frontier we don't understand how to
prove a lower bound but maybe threshold
of majority is the same as LT 2 and then
we have a lower bond in fact it was
interesting to note yesterday that yes i
just talked that you know as far as
satisfiability algorithms are concerned
they seem to be algorithmically the same
okay so maybe threshold of majority is
just the same as 22 and it would maybe
surprising because of this nice result
due to goldman hostile raj more of who
showed that majority of majority is the
same as majority of threshold so it's
feasible that adding weights at the
bottom do not matter and this was asked
as an open problem by first by Emanuel
Moroka in 2005 and then by Hansen and
Podolski in 2010 well it turns out that
they are not
this is the main result of our paper
which which shows that there is a
function in threshold of threshold and
it will turn out to be involved
equalities and it's a very simple
function that has very large sign rank
and therefore is not integral of
majority okay so that's the new result
and here we need
I haven't yet specified the function but
I'll do so very quickly it has large
sign rank and just a quick survey of
what some past work on sign rank how
much time we have so let me skip this so
let me just tell you how we got to this
function so a natural candidate in depth
two would be to look at you know the the
the hardest function the hardest
threshold is this Universal threshold
and if you look at a universal threshold
or n Square log and bits by just setting
the bits you can simulate every
threshold right so a natural candidate
is if anything is hard
it better be Universal threshold of
universal threshold but this is the
problem that typically you face when you
are proving lower bounds then it's not a
nice function I mean the only handle
that we have for proving sign rank is
due to foster and to analyze the
spectral property of such as such a
function is not clear how to go about it
so we want to make it something more
structured and let's go back to the
communication game that showed the
threshold of majority has small sign
rank
so there what was happening was you know
you were you were sampling a sub circuit
okay and then sending Alice and Bob were
jointly computing that sub circuit now
the minimum thing that you need if I
have threshold of F and I want to have
large side rank so I want to prevent a
UPP protocol from computing this
function easily is that the
deterministic complexity of this
function should be large right because
if the deterministic complexity of this
function is small I will still have a
unbounded error protocol and this
immediately sets a natural question well
though the the cardinal function
that we have which has large
deterministic complexities equality
right so so one would expect the
threshold of equality would have large
sign drag it doesn't seem like the knife
protocol would be able to do that it
turns out that this threshold is also if
I if I again give a general threshold I
don't know how to analyze the spectral
properties of threshold of equality so
we look at something much more
structured which has been looked at in
the 90s starting from the work of
Richard beagle a lot of times especially
in the approximation Theory literature
this is the nice function called odd
match bit which basically outputs 1 if
the leftmost so I've written here isn't
-1 1 if it outputs minus 1 if the
leftmost one is that an odd index okay
so this is this you should think of is
like a decision list ok this can be
simulated easily by a decision list so
anyway it just it just outputs minus 1
if the leftmost index is leftmost 1 is
at an odd index so if the first if the
first index was 1 it outputs minus 1 if
this was 0 but the second index was 1
then you output 0 and so on so this it's
not hard to see that this is also a
linear threshold function of with large
weights and it turns out this provides
us with the right structure so we look
at odd max bit of equality this is again
not hard to see that this is in
threshold of threshold well or max bit
is in threshold equality is an exact
threshold and I leave it as an
interesting exercise to show that
anything a threshold of exact our
shortly is in threshold low threshold it
also is an AC zero ok this function is
very simple it's in AC 0 as well as in
threshold of threshold and it turns out
that this function is has very large
sign that it has to be n to the 1/4 sign
right so this shows this gives us the
separation let me skip a little bit and
just maybe in two minutes to tell you
about the communication complexity
implications so the communication
complexity implications were observed by
Mika and kindly pointed us out that it
solves one of his opening problems so a
long-standing open problem in
communication complexity due to Bobby
Frankel and Simons is to prove lower
bounds for the polynomial hierarchy
which is like a c0 of rectangles and it
is very closely related to matrix
rigidity so this problem has been open
for a long time a much simpler problem
is to even show lower bounds against the
depth to the second level of this
hierarchy
razbolo and chef stop in 2009 showed
that this is already very hard because
you know this contains functions of
large sign R and a sign rank in
communication complexity is the
strongest tool that we have to prove
lower bounds so this is this was the
communication complexity landscape which
due to the work of rosboroughs and sure
shutoff showed that the second level of
the hierarchy there is a sort of a sign
rank barrier because this has functions
of like sign rank and then there is this
class P to the M a so everything below
this we have lower bound techniques but
P to the M a was not known to have you
know sign a large sign rank however we
had no technique to prove lower bounds
in fact P to the MA was possibly not
even looked at before our before our
work because there was no reason to look
at it so the point is P to the end there
are somewhere between P to the NP and
and the second level you know the sign
lines here where did it start it was not
clear and what it turns out that the
function that I have talked about this
actually has a P to the M a protocol
it's a very simple protocol first thing
to notice is there is an MA protocol for
all of equality why because if you have
a or of equality you know Merlin can
point out which equality is one and then
Alice and Bob can confirm using
probabilistic verification because
equality has small randomized
communication complexity so all of
equality is in it is in MA and using
that and binary search you can sort of
find out the first equality that that is
right you can repeatedly do this use
order of equality as an Oracle keep on
finding whether whether it's in the
right-half if it's just not then when
you move to the left and so on until you
find the first position where the first
equality which is one and then you know
whether it's odd or even so there's a
very simple p2 DMA protocol using binary
search so P to the MA therefore it has
this function and what what we have
known as an update for them to the
landscape is that well there's a reason
why the P to the MA
is seems to be a class that for which we
have no lower bounds because assigned
rank barrier sort of comes down here
okay and and it sort of just seems as
Mika pointed us out that P to the M is
just tantalizingly out of reach because
we have lower bound sins against MA okay
and we also have lower bounce against P
to the N NP there are multiple ways of
proving lower bounce against P to the N
P so P to the MA if you try to relax it
just a little bit whichever way you do
naturally you have lower bounds so P to
the MA seems to be the right place where
lower bound technique stop because we
have this and the explanation perhaps is
because we have black signer and let me
just there's no time for this let me
just mention some open problems well of
course this remains the the main problem
that we started with and unfortunately
we still have no idea how to prove lower
bounds but I think what is interesting
is that this class decision list of
exact thresholds comes out here as a
natural class well I've changed equality
to exact threshold because although
decision list of equality has large sine
rang but it's an AC 0 so we can apply
random restrictions of course and prove
lower bounds but this is the smallest
class which seems to be resistant to
random restrictions and to an has large
sign rank two important techniques so if
you do bottom-up lower bound the the
main technique that we have is random
restriction which this circuit class
seems to be immune to if you do top-down
then we see the strongest technique
seems to be sign rank and we know that
this class also has large sign
so it would be interesting to prove that
inner product for example has no such
small circuits one surprising thing I
want to point out this if you paid
attention to Mina's talk if you change
if you if you replace this by just thr a
a threshold then it turns out that you
can actually prove lower bounds for this
class so somehow exact treshold makes it
hard and has larger sign right and the
other thing is maybe this so we were
able to show that it has large sign rank
but maybe does not a full sign rank so
what you can prove an upper bound on the
sign language cannot be maximal maybe
it's to the sub-linear something since
inner product has maximal sign rank that
would also be enough to show that this
can't compute inner product okay and in
general it's not clear why threshold of
threshold should have maximally large
sign rank so that might be one way of
proving a lower bounds and the other
target is true if you're interested in
communication complexity is to prove
lower bounce against P to the MA
protocols the time is now after four
[Applause]